hi in this module i'm going to talk
about local search a strategy for
approximately computing the maximum
weight
assignment
a constraint satisfaction problem
so remember that a csv is defined by a
factor graph which includes a set of
variables x1 through xn
and a set of factors f1 through fm where
each factor is a function that depends
on a subset of the variables and returns
a non-negative number
each assignment to all the variables has
a weight given by the product of all the
factors evaluated on assignment
and the objective is to compute the
maximum weight assignment as usual
so so far we've seen backtracking search
and beam search
and both of these search algorithms
works by extending partial assignments
you start with the empty assignments
and then you assign one variable and you
sign another variable until you get to a
complete assignment and then maybe you
backtrack or maybe you don't
so local search is going to be a little
bit different it's going to
modify complete assignments so you're
going to start with a random assignment
and then you're going to choose one
variable and you change it choose
another variable and change it more kind
of like house maintenance rather than
building a house
so one of the advantages of local search
is that gives you additional flexibility
you can pick any variable and try to
improve it
whereas
backtracking search and beam search you
have to do things in a certain order or
beam search once you've assigned a
variable you can't go back
and backtracking search you can't
backtrack but
you can't really kind of backtrack
backtrack out of order
so recall our running example object
tracking so at each time position you
observe a noisy sensor reading of a
particular object you observe
0
2
and 2 as the positions of the object and
you're trying to figure out where this
object was
so we did model this as a csp
where we have
three of observational factors
one which favors x1 equals
zero o2 which favors x2 equals to
o3 which favors x3 equals two and we
have two transition factors
that
favor
subsequent positions being close by
so let's jump in and suppose we just
have
a complete assignment zero zero one
okay the question is how do we improve
this
well let's look at um the weight of this
assignment so the weight of this
assignment is 2
because 0 agrees with 0
times 2 because 0 agrees with 0
times 0 uh-oh because these two are too
far apart
um times one because these only differ
by one
and times one because
by one
but you get a zero so that's not a very
good assignment so how can we improve
let's try to reassign x2 to something
else
let's try to
assign it to some v so we can set v
equals 0 1 or 2.
and for each of these
alternate assignments and compute its
weight
and then we simply take the assignment
with the best weight in this case it's
uh this one
which sets x2 to be one
then we end up with a new assignment
which is better than the old one so
mission accomplished
so we can refine this strategy a little
bit more so
suppose we're trying to
assign x2
the weight of a new assignment
where x2 has been replaced with sum v
is as follows so you're multiplying all
the factors in the csp together o 1 t 1
o 2 t
three
but
note that
only some of the factors depend on v
in particular o1 and o3 don't depend on
v
so no matter what v is these are the
same which means that we can ignore them
and um just evaluate the factors that
involve
x2
so this is an idea of locality which
leverages the
structure of the csp
when evaluating possible reassignments
to some variable x i we only need to
consider the factors that depend on x i
so in a factor graph where there's lots
and lots of variables and you're trying
to reassign one variable which might
have a small neighborhood
then you're saving a lot of effort
so now we're ready to define
our local search algorithm which is
called iterated conditional modes sounds
fancy but it's really simple
the idea is that we're going to start
x to be a random complete assignment
and we're going to loop through
x1 through xn
and then keep on going until
we converge or we run out of time
um what we're going to do is we're going
to try to reassign x on okay so we're
going to consider each possible value
that x i could take on
and then we're going to update the
current assignment x
with that value
okay so this um that produces an
assignment x v
and then we're going to compute the
weights
of each of these x v's and choose the
one with the highest weight remember in
computing the weight we only need to
evaluate
the factors that
touch x i and also notice that this
looks remarkably like you know greedy
search or beam search
um there is a substantial difference
in that here x are complete assignments
not
partial assignments so this is not
extending an assignment so much as
replacing x i
uh with a read
so pictorially what this looks like is
um you
start with x1
so by convention
unshaded nodes are the ones that are
meant to be
reassigned and shaded ones are the ones
that are fixed
so you pick up x1 and you say can i
change it to make it better
and then you
pick some value of x1 then you go to
x2 and say can i make uh change x2 to
make this uh assignment better
and then you go to x3 and then you go
back to x1 and say hey can i make it
better by changing x1 again you keep on
going until
it converges
so here's a demo on the object tracking
example
um
so
at the start of the algorithm we're just
going to initialize this with a random
assignment 0 1 2 and it has a weight
of 4. um and now i'm going to try to
maximize variable one uh x1 given
everything else so let's consider
alternative values of x1 so it could be
zero one or two for each of these i'm
going to compute
its weight only evaluating the factors
that touch x1 so in this case it's only
o1 and t1 that touch x1 so i only need
to evaluate those
compute the weights
choose the best one breaking ties
arbitrarily so i
choose x1 0 which means i didn't change
so now let me step
so now i'm looking at one
x2
um and can i change anything
nope can i what about here x3
um
assigned is assigned to
what can i do
well i compute the weights
and here i
am choosing
x
three to be one okay so
um i change that assignment
and now i go back to x1 and iterate
and it looks like i've uh converged
because i'm not changing anything
so i've converged to
an assignment with a weight of 4 which
if you remember is not the optimum uh
maximum weight assignment the maximum
weight assignment is
um has weight eight
so again iterative conditional modes is
is going to give you an okay solution
but not necessarily the best one
so convergence properties
but the good news is that
the weight of your assignment is
not going to go down it's going to
always increase or stay the same each
iteration
and this is because when you're trying
to reassign a variable you can always
choose the old value
and maintain the same weight so any
change must be increasing the weight
so this means that it converges in a
finite number of iterations because
there's only finite number of possible
assignments so you can only increase the
weight
a finite number of times
this uh can get second off local optimum
as we've seen and it's not generally
guaranteed to find the optimum
assignment
so just a quick note is that there's two
ways around this
one is that there is a version of this
where you can change two variables or
maybe three variables at a time
and that allows you to perhaps get out
of your local optimum
and another thing
we can do is add randomness so at each
step we could just add
choose the best option or just choose a
random option and this will also allow
us to
escape these local optimum
or we can use something like give
sampling which i'll talk about
in a future module which will add
stochasticity to
um
icm
okay so here is the summary
so
um
let me summarize actually
um all the search algorithms for csps
that we've encountered so first we
looked at backtracking search
so the strategy is to extend partial
assignments and then backtrack when we
get to
the complete assignment
the backtracking search is
exact
it computes the actual
maximum weight assignment it's the only
algorithm that we're considering that
does that in general
but the main problem is that the time
can be exponential
in the number of variables
then we looked at a beam search
which
extends also extends partial assignments
and here we're trading off accuracy for
time so this is approximate
it will only give you a
an okay solution
but it's linear in the number of
variables
and local search um we saw iterative
conditional modes which
does local search by choosing the best
value of a variable at each given time
um is a different strategy here we're
starting with complete assignments and
modifying them to make them better
so here it's also
approximate
but it's fast just like beam search
okay so that concludes this module